und damit herzlich willkommen in bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder der
gestern geburtstag hatte 55 jahre alt
vor der herzlichen glückwunsch dazu
glückwunsch
zunächst aber er seinen guten morgen und
vielen dank dafür sehr gerne zunächst
einmal müssen wir über die bilder aus
münchen von gestern abend sprechen was
möchten sie den menschen die dort
gestern auf die straße gegangen sind
gerne sagen
und ich glaube dass wir insgesamt in
einer aufgewühlten situation sind bis
jetzt im jahr zwei der pandemie wir
haben die situation dass wir
möglicherweise eine weile in bayern gut
überstanden haben letzte viertel liegen
holt trotz omikron auf platz 14 in
deutschland und trotzdem besteht die
gefahr einer neuen herausforderung durch
diese omikron
debatte die wir jetzt haben werden ich
glaube ein ist es wichtig wir müssen
versuchen in diesem jahr neben dem
strammen verkünden von maßnahmen und
ständig neuen über allen von konzepten
auch darüber nachzudenken wie wir die
gesellschaft wieder heilen und versöhnen
können klar wir müssen uns abgrenzen von
denen die versuchen über und mittels
corona andere ziele zu verfolgen das ist
insbesondere der rechtsradikale bereich
sind insbesondere diejenigen die hoch
aggressiv sind aber es gibt auch sehr
viele menschen die schlicht und einfach
verunsichert sind genervt gemüse müde
sind und gestresst und für die brauchen
wir auch ein angebot auf dauer zu
gespräch miteinander
und wie gesagt wir müssen schauen dass
wir diese gesellschaft am ende auch
wieder heilen versöhnen ich möchte ihnen
gerne eine szene von gestern abend
zeigen die einem besonders nagel die
viele gefühle auslöst sind auslöst
zehntausende menschen schauen sich das
derzeit auf twitter an ein mann der bei
der demonstration teilnimmt von der
polizei abgeführt wird unternehmen ist
sein kleiner sohn der weint klar ist
natürlich wissen wir nicht was vor
dieser szene passiert ist was nach
dieser szene passiert ist klar es aber
auch viele menschen nutzen auch dieses
video lassen sie uns hier einmal
gemeinsam reinschauen
wir sehen hier den mangel in der grünen
kapuzenjacke
[Musik]
und gleich können wir auch dem kleinen
sohn den sie rechts im bild erkennen
können ins gesicht blicken gehören auch
polizisten schreien die schreiende
erwehren sie sich nicht und kommen sie
jetzt mit und wir sehen es kind dort
stehen
der ratlos daneben steht und nicht weiß
was er machen soll während sein vater
deutschland polizeiwagen gebracht wird
hier können wir den kleinen jungen der
plötzlichkeit ins gesicht schauen also
da ist es klar wir wissen nicht was
davor passiert ist wir wissen nicht was
danach passiert ist und dennoch hat uns
dieses video heute morgen wahnsinnig
berührt was löst das in ihnen aus
ja sie sollten da habe ich völlig es
verständnis aber ich glaube sie selber
sehen ja daraus für sich selbst auch die
aufgabe noch mal die recherche zu
intensivieren das war vorher was ist
danach ich glaube das gehört zu der
beurteilung einer solchen situation dazu
wir haben öfters jetzt erlebt das ganz
bewusst bei solchen demonstrationen
unterschiedliche
auf situationen entstanden sind das ist
eine schwierige herausforderung
andererseits muss die sicherheit und
ordnung gewährleistet sein das
demonstrationsrecht ist ein hohes gut
auch das muss gewährleistet sein und dem
spannungsfeld bewegen wir uns daher
insgesamt macht die polizei eine sehr
sehr gute arbeit und ich bin sicher sie
werden die nächsten stunden und tage da
noch mal auch dann noch mal an anfügen
was vorher und nachher passiert ist das
ist ein ganz wichtiger aspekt deswegen
habe ich den hier auch so herausgestellt
als wir ihnen dieses video gezeigt hat
mich interessiert aber ja schon früh
stand für mich eine frage sagen wir mal
von mutter so vater finden sie man
sollte kinder auf diese demonstration
überhaupt mitnehmen
ich mische mich nicht in das elternrecht
1 das müssen die eltern selber
entscheiden aber es ist ganz ganz
wichtig dass an der stelle wir einfach
immer versuchen das richtige maß zu
halten ich glaube bei all den fragen die
wir jetzt bei krone haben gerade jetzt
zu die neuen herausforderungen ist es
wichtig das richtige augenmaß zu
erhalten sagt für viele ist dieses
corona mittlerweile eine art
glaubenssache geworden wir müssen aber
zunächst mal schauen welche gefährdung
wirklich existiert für die mpk es zum
beispiel ganz entscheidend für die
morgige dass der expertenrat eine klare
empfehlung abgibt wie gefährlich ist
hongkong wenn die inzidenz und stark
steigen ist das eine aber wie wirkt sich
das in dem verlauf dann auch für die
krankenhaus führt dazu aus deswegen
glaube ich sind wir jetzt klug beraten
auch für die nächsten wochen jetzt uns
nicht in glaubens kämpfe zu versteifen
dass wir uns nicht aber jeder
zurückziehen auf seine maximale position
sondern dass wir versuchen brücken zu
bauen und die vernünftigste brücke ist
die wissenschaft und das sind braucht es
jetzt eine klare grundlage eine einfache
und verständliche kommunikation dass ich
hoffe ich auch sehr dass die ampel
morgen klare vorschläge unterbreitet die
nachvollziehbar wissenschaftlich
begründet sind und dann am ende auch
vertrieb was in angesichts der dimension
die omikron bedeutet vor allem bei der
frage wie gefährlich ist schon wirklich
glauben hilft nicht weiter das stimmt
herr söder die zahlen die allerdings
geliefert werden die sind so oft eine
glaubensfrage können sie für sich
beanspruchen sie und ihr
gesundheitsminister in bayern dass sie
sagen wir kennen sie die wahren corona
zahlen
ich habe den gesundheitsminister extra
vor diesem gespräch noch einmal
angerufen und er sagt bei uns waren über
5000 leute im kontakt tracing auch über
die feiertage letzten tage im einsatz
ich glaube dass die dimension der zahlen
wohl schon in die richtige richtung geht
es war auch zu erwarten dass es nach den
ferien stärker wird bei uns enden die
ferien erst sozusagen in dieser woche
und wer beim nächsten woche dann erst
den normalen schulbeginn wieder oder den
normal starb nach den ferien was mir
insgesamt jedoch auffällt es scheint
hier gewisse differenzen zwischen dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium
ist diese dinge müssten schon versucht
werden so zu harmonisieren das dort mit
einer stimme gesprochen unter den anders
als bei früheren fällen ist in der tat
so die verunsicherung riesengroß und wir
diskutieren über den einen oder anderen
aspekt und vernachlässigen dann einfach
mal die grund herausforderung wir
brauchen vorsicht wir brauchen augenmaß
aber auch verletzlicher zahlenbasis auf
vernünftigen nachvollziehbaren
wissenschaftlich entscheidungen die dann
auch vor gerichten standhalten das ist
glaube ich in dieser phase ganz ganz
entscheidend auch für die nächsten
wochen dass wir bei einer solchen
omikron wand wie er sagte auf einen
zukommt und man merkte wie die zahlen
steigen auch genau wissen was wir tun
genau auch entscheiden können dazu
braucht es jetzt zunächst mal vorschläge
und der neuen bundesregierung wie sie
glaubt diese pandemie in den nächsten
wochen gestalten und bewältigen zu
können sie haben die zweifel
angesprochen an den rk ii zahlen 57
prozent der deutschen zweifeln an den
zahlen und das rkw zweifelte an den
eigenen zahlen auch am 29.12 hat das
robert-koch-institut gesagt naja so
mitte januar ab dem 10 januar könne man
wieder belastbare zahlen haben so lange
ohne belastbares zahlenmaterial sie sind
vermutlich keiner der über die feiertage
und über den jahreswechsel komplett die
füße hochgelegt habt und ihren beamten
gesagt du kannst alle lange urlaub
machen die korona krise macht jetzt mal
eine pause das ist doch ein versagen mit
ansage
minute sichert die beurteilung so stimmt
ich kann nicht dazu sagen was das lka
sagt der zuständige behördenleiter ist
der bundesgesundheitsminister also der
oberste chef des lka deswegen könnte das
sicher profit auskunft geben bei ihnen
ich kann nur sagen was ich unseren
gesundheitsbehörden abgefragt habe dort
wird weiter gearbeitet klar ist aber
natürlich auch nicht alle gehen in den
feiertagen am heiligabend oder am ersten
januar dann quasi zum arzt oder wollen
sich zu testen gehen lassen sich
symptome sind ja zum teil auch danach
eingetreten deswegen glaube ich dass die
realistischen zahlen so glaube ich ist
die einschätzung so vermute ich mal
gewesen vom rkw über die dimension über
die dimension einer neuen entwicklung
dass die dann jetzt in den nächsten
tagen ausgebaut allerdings alle zahlen
die wir haben glauben wir dass sie
belastbar sind also jetzt ist in den
nächsten tagen morgen aber schon da
steht die em tk ankommt das dann nicht
schon ein bisschen zu früh wenn die
zahlen jetzt noch gar nicht belastbar
sind
ja ehrlich diese frage habe ich mir auch
gestellt also man merkt zwar dass die
zahlen anziehen übrigens auch bei denen
die noch vor einigen wochen ganz
besonders auch immer uns im süden
herausgefordert haben sie wissen ja wir
haben im süden vor einigen wochen bei
der vierten welle waren wir als erste
dran werbung was auch ganz klar war weil
die nachbarn für weiter waren bei der
stelle österreich dezember das im norden
ganz genauso profi auch sehr dass wir
diesmal endlich mal aufhören aus diesen
mit soll ich sagen aus diesem ranking
debatten herauszukommen ist kein
wettbewerb bei corona haben alle die
gleiche herausforderung so habe aber das
gefühl dass morgen ist alles noch
insofern etwas zu früh weil wir da noch
etwas im nebel stochern insbesondere bei
der zentralen frage wenn es weitere
massnahmen geben sollte dann müssen die
gut wissenschaftlich begründet sein ich
habe gehört dass gestern in einer
schalte insbesondere auf der
beamtenebene dort vom expertenrat keine
empfehlung kam zur verschärfung von
maßnahmen
dies muss jetzt mal geklärt werden denn
ohne wissenschaftliche expertise macht
es ja keinen sinn was sie macht ist zum
beispiel dass alle regeln einheitlich
sind zum beispiel die ffb zwei maske
mehr verwendet wird wir brauchen
dringend dass auf jeden fall eine
verständliche und vernünftige quarantäne
regel so wie es nachbarländer und sitzt
derzeit der vormachen nicht nur wegen
der kritischen infrastruktur also den
krankenhäusern polizei und feuerwehr
sondern eben auch für das normale
alltagsleben
wenn wir da drei vier fünf verschiedene
charaktere modelle haben dann wird es am
ende auch nicht verständlich seien
deswegen mein dringender appell dazu
liegt im moment ehrlich gesagt noch
nichts vor es ist ein tag vor der mpk
ich selber habe noch keine verlässliche
aussage und auch
basis dafür das ist schon alles sehr
sehr kurzfristig und deswegen muss das
klug überlegt sein denn sonst passiert
ist wie beim einzelhandel zweig das
wieder vieles von den gerichten frage
gestellt oder ein punkt ist noch ganz
wichtig ehrlich gesagt ich habe warte
jetzt endlich ein sauberes hilfspaket
für unseren mittelstand und wirtschaft
wir haben nicht wirklich die maßnahmen
verbessert der bund hat 60 milliarden an
corona groschen eigentlich zurückgelegt
corona notgroschen dies soll aber für
was anderes ausgegeben werden ist ja
auch der punkt der verfassungsrechtlich
schwierig ist dies muss jetzt verwendet
werden nicht nur wie er habe gesagt wir
wir sagen rückzahlungen sollen später
kommen solche moratorien werden uns
nicht helfen soll wir brauchen jetzt
verbesserte maßnahmen für handel
gastronomie schausteller viele andere
selbstständige die sind auch in der
kulturbranche die von auch übrigens
zweig zweige plus so betroffen sind es
darf man nicht unterschätzen
deswegen sollte der bund seine
hilfspaket noch mal massivst aufstocken
auch dass wir morgen ein gutes signal
aber sie reden was dann dass sie den
corona gipfel morgen die mpk für nicht
richtig gut vorbereitet halten
also ich habe ein bisschen zu ärgern sie
wissen dass ich zum team vor sich gehört
sie haben mich ja auch das schon oft
dafür sehr geschimpft in diesem fahrrad
oder in der statistischen begleitung ich
bleibe auch ich bleibe auch beim team
vorsicht aber auch beim team augenmaß
ein augenmaß heißt wir brauchen jetzt
eine abgestimmte vorlage der expertenrat
muss uns sagen wie er omikron einschätzt
es ist nicht so dass es keine daten gibt
um uns herum kann man ja relativ stark
sehen wie es sich entwickelt wir haben
die situation in großbritannien wir
haben die situation in italien werden
die situation in frankreich also unseren
fast nachbarn auch dänemark sind der
sehr stark betroffen haben erste
erfahrung zwar wie wirkt sich omikron im
verlauf aus wie wirkt sich das auf die
krankenhaus situation aus natürlich in
der relation zu der jeweiligen
institution das ist auch zum beispiel
jetzt klar wir haben ja jetzt in den
letzten tagen mehrere im
herausforderungsmodus init zb das
boostern läuft er jetzt erste welle ist
gelaufen jetzt läuft der zweite ansatz
wir sollten zum beispiel überlegen ist
israel ein beispiel sollten wir nicht
noch stärker und schneller sie sind
alles fragen die eigentlich einer
sauberen wissenschaftlichen basis
erfordern und der körper nicht sozusagen
in einer firma oder politiker
abgestimmten haltung auch schon da
möchtest du es ein bisschen mehr oder
weniger machen also ich plädiere dafür
für eine einheitlichkeit und ich hoffe
dann auch ehrlich gesagt nicht dass dann
morgen wenn wir diskutieren zwischendrin
wieder irgendein gremium des bundes
vielleicht srk oder ein anderes dann
natürlich gegenteiligem fehler macht
wirklich vergessen es für wird ja die
menschen sowieso aber das ist auch keine
sehr stabile grundlage für eine beratung
in einer solchen wirklich also
hochrangigen konferenz also sie hoffen
dass lothar wieler morgen früh keine
pressemitteilung raus schickt bevor es
dazu ergebnissen habe ich mich aber noch
einmal nachhaken bedeutet dass ohne
abgestimmte vorlage wird es keine
verschärfungen geben
das weiß ich nicht weiß nicht was als
vorschlag kommt ich sage nur dass das
gut begründet sein muss also wir haben
jetzt hier erlebt zum beispiel bei 2g im
einzelhandel hat es ja verschiedene
gerichtsentscheidung geben in einigen
bundesländern wie niedersachsen wurde es
komplett aufgehoben in einigen
bundesländern bei uns gab's
einzelbereiche die dann verändert würden
was diese abgrenzung des alltäglichen
lebens betrifft ich finde jetzt gerade
bei omikron sollte man beim neustart in
dieses jahr auch angesichts der
aufgewühlten gesellschaftlichen und
herausfordernden corona situationen
wirklich mit größter sorgfalt und
weniger heißer nadel mit klarer experten
grundlage und juristische klarheit dann
auch herangehen an wir können es uns
nicht leisten erneut in etliche
widersprüche systembrüche zu gehen dass
sie muss das jetzt im sozusagen sitzen
und deswegen sage ich ganz offen ist die
mpk morgen möglicherweise ein paar tage
zu früh angesetzt ist kein vorwurf aber
mir ist es lieber wir beraten dann
morgen und entscheiden dann lieber ein
paar tage später wenn die
wissenschaftliche basis definitiv besser
ist das muss jetzt halt noch geklärt
werden ich jedenfalls habe bis zur
jetzigen stunde kein abschließendes
empfehlungs papier für eine
weitreichende entscheidung die dann
getroffen werden soll für millionen von
menschen und vor allem für viele
existenzen bitte noch mal wirklich zu
sehen wir kommen jetzt langsam an den
bereich gerade für den mittelstand und
die selbstständigen geht es langsam
wirklich ans eingemachte und da braucht
es mehr unterstützung hilfe und
sensibilität ist angekommen also die mpk
kommt zu früh oder die vorbereitung
kommt zu spät ein bisschen so sieht es
auch bei der impfpflicht aus da war im
dezember unser aller eindruck die
impfpflicht kommt auf jeden fall da hat
auch der damals noch nicht ganz kanzler
olaf scholz richtig druck gemacht hat
gesagt er ist für die impfpflicht noch
im dezember würden der erste anträge
kommen ist aber nicht so im bundes
bisher kein antrag dazu offenbar auch
weil das juristisch ziemlich schwierig
ist das zu formulieren wenn man das denn
möchte herr söder sie waren auch immer
befürworter dieser allgemeinen pflicht
kommt die denn jetzt wirklich noch
ich gebe zu ich bin auch etwas
verunsichert die fragen die sie stellen
also dass dies juristisch herausfordern
das ist absolut richtig auch das
verfahren wie es stattfinden soll muss
genau geklärt werden und deswegen halte
ich es auch für falsch dass das über
gruppenanträge einzelner abgeordneter
aus dem parlament heraus kommt das muss
das bundesgesundheitsministerium das
muss die regierung vorlegen die
regierung muss einen vorschlag machen
wann für wen welche gruppen und wie eine
solche impfpflicht umgesetzt werden soll
man hat sich darauf committed die
bundesregierung die ampel hat sich
committed darauf der bundeskanzler
selbst hat gesagt wer führung bestellt
der bekommt sie auch die hand führung
gestellt jetzt bekommen wir sozusagen
irgendwelche gruppenanträge die völlig
unklar sind wie sie zustande kommen soll
ich halte es für einen schweren fehler
muss intelligenz von schweren fehler
dass nicht ein klarer vorschlag
existiert gerade bei einem so in der tat
ja gesellschaftlich umstrittenen thema
wenn der impfpflicht es ja erkennbar
braucht das absolute souveränität in der
formulierung und auch in der klarheit
was dahinter stehen kann deswegen
empfinde ich das als falsch dass die
bundesregierung sich dieser
herausforderung nicht stellt ist
versucht über gruppenanträge zu machen
der einzige grund kann ja nur sein dass
es innerhalb der ampel schwerste
verwerfungen unterschiede gibt die fdp
insbesondere christian nimmt mass er
dafür herr kubicki ist nun sagen wir mal
sehr sehr deutlich dagegen auch mit
worten die ein imam etwas ratlos
zurücklassen wenn ich das so an
vorsichtig andeuten darf wenig dass die
heute am dreikönigs treffen gleich alle
wieder ausflippen aber das ist ja alles
keine botschaft sie genauso mit
telegramm wir kennen das telegramm eine
echte herausforderung bei uns ist und
dass da wirklich viel an einer wirklich
schwierigen dingen laufen jeder berichte
darüber auch er und gleichzeitig gibt es
null reaktion wir wollen da mal jetzt
mit denen reden schickten einen brief
nach ich glaube nach dubai oder abu
dhabi in dieses hochhaus wo das büro
eigentlich gar keine ist außerdem
offiziell sitzt das ist doch alles
absurd ist du alles ab so kann man auch
nicht regieren verstehen sich damit also
ich war natürlich eine ampel hat noch
sie erst 100 tage aber das fehlt alles
das fehlt alles kurz noch mal bei der
impfpflicht zum beispiel ansprechen
wollten als beispiel ansprechen für zwei
zentrale punkte sind pflicht und auch
diese das thema hassel hitze das sind ja
zwei hervorragende punkte beide müssen
es souverän wirkende ampel und die
impfpflicht umso mehr die aber vor allen
dingen ja auch draußen im land total
umstritten und polarisieren der klare
mehrheit für die impfpflicht so war es
zumindest vor weihnachten aber
möglicherweise schrumpft ja auch da die
unterstützung das ist schon ein
hochkomplexes thema jetzt sehen wir dass
es diesen streit innerhalb der ampel
geht gibt und der zeitplan
möglicherweise ja gar nicht mehr
einzuhalten ist erst ab märz für die
impfpflicht halten sie das noch für
realistisch
sehr schwer kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass das einzuhalten wäre
und ich mache mir halt auch ein bisschen
ich bin mal bissel sorge was die gesamte
glaubwürdigkeit der neuen
bundesregierung betrifft die alte
regierung hat auch viele fehler gemacht
und sie ist deswegen auch nicht mehr im
amt
wahrscheinlich ist das auch einer der
gründe jetzt muss die neue regierung bei
dieser phase man spürte richtig dass
auch da nicht umfragen das vertrauen
leicht zurückgeht das sage ich jetzt
nicht parteipolitisch sondern
staatspolitisch das ist nicht gut im
moment sondern gut wäre wenn man jetzt
klare schritte kommuniziert und sagt
wann und wo und warum und wenn das jetzt
so hin und her geht und keiner weiß
genau was und für wen und wann wie sie
angesprochen haben es muss ja auch eine
struktur gefunden werden und eine
antwort gefunden werden das auch dann
sondern wie die besetzung stattfinden
soll wie was bedeutet es für zukünftige
mutationen wie oft geht man davon aus
dass das stattfinden sollte alles in der
tat zig fragen und da glaube ich muss
die vorbereitung besser sein als dass
sich zehn abgeordnete zusammensetzen und
einen gruppenantrag formuliert das ist
regierungs kernbereich der exekutiven
und deswegen erwarten wir dass
schlichtweg einen vorschlag dazu ich
habe mich dort mit friedrich merz
abgestimmte erwarten einen vorschlag der
ampel dazu und nicht einen vorschlag von
56 wir sind ihr vorschlag dazu denn ist
verunsichert doch viele das nicht
absehbar ist wie viele booster man
braucht das ist ja das kernproblem dass
wir jetzt neuerdings haben bei der
impfpflicht dass man auch so weit gehen
müsste dass man menschen eventuell
verpflichtet alle paar monate eine neue
impfung zu erhalten wie sehr ist das
dann noch tragbar
die herausforderung ist immer was ist
das schutzgut schutzgut ist in einem die
gesundheit der menschen die verhinderung
der überlastung des gesundheitssystems
und das glaube ich auch sehr sehr
zentrales freiheit die freiheit und
frieden in unserer gesellschaft das ist
ja die eigentliche debatte den neben der
medizinischen steht die
gesellschaftliche die wirtschaftliche
die soziale freiheit die liberale frage
die werden und da gibt es
unterschiedliche antworten darauf die
einen sagen ach lass die impfpflicht weg
versuchen ist nochmal nochmal nochmal
und reden noch mal auf denjenigen der
überhaupt nichts hin verlassen will und
die anderen sagen vielleicht ist so eine
grundstruktur entscheidungen pflicht und
sie heißt aber daran fest dann aber das
sind so viele wie sie es ja zu recht
ich glaube dass das ein wichtiger
beitrag sein kann sowohl medizinisch als
auch gesellschaftlich aber nur dann nur
dann wenn es einen klaren vorschlag gibt
wer wann wie oft dieses die frage die
sie ansprechen sind ja genau die fragen
jetzt kann ich die und ich kann auch
kein abgeordnete beantworten die kann
letztlich nur die bundesregierung
beantworten warum weil sie die
ressourcen hat juristisch die ressourcen
weil sie am medizinischen ressourcen hat
auch die experten sind ja dabei man hat
der bewusst gesagt man fragt den den
ethikrat der hat sich dann so halb halt
knapp dafür entschieden auch das muss
man natürlich wahrnehmen und jetzt bin
ich einfach sehr gespannt was da
rauskommt verstehen sie das ist jetzt
führung das ist jetzt einfach führung in
einer der zentralen fragen ist es keine
besondere führung energiepreise zu
erhöhen und dann kein ausgleich zu
schaffen ist keine führung aber man
brauche ich dir jetzt kleiner schlenker
man bräuchte jetzt umgekehrt aber dafür
in einer so zentralen frage die ihr
tatsächlich auf füllt und die auch für
das land wichtiges braucht es einen
vorschlag der regierung da können ja
nicht ablassen davon das muss die
regierung vorschlagen nächste wichtige
alltagsfragen ist die bene im moment
ganz viele arbeitnehmer betroffen auch
hier im haus ganz genauso natürlich in
den schulen man hat kontakt zu einer
omikron person zu einem micon mitschüler
und zack muss man 14 tage in quarantäne
obwohl man gesund obwohl man negativ
getestet es können wir die quarantäne
nicht wie in frankreich komplett
abräumen bei kontakt
also wir müssen sie deutlich verändern
auch da braucht es noch mal ein
vorschlag ich habe gestern gehört dass
in der gesundheitsministerkonferenz der
gesundheitsminister den vorschlag
gemacht hat den die gesundheitsminister
der länder als nicht akzeptabel oder
umsetzbar angesehen haben der war so
kompliziert ich habe dann eine kurze
übersicht gesehen die beim besten willen
also auch selbst beim besten willen man
nicht versteht und für verwirrung führt
deswegen wird jetzt noch mal da ist der
auftrag erteilt von zu überarbeiten und
morgen einen vorschlag zu machen ich
halte es für sinnvoller könig das ganze
land einsparen und wir müssen klar
unterscheiden ja wer krank ist und wer
nicht krank ist dann muss es dann doch
deutliche veränderung geben wir haben
jetzt schon für die booster eine andere
situation ich erwarte man und hoffe sehr
vorschlag zu machen der einfacher klarer
und unbürokratische ist und der auch die
möglichkeit schafft trotz omikron das
leben zu ermöglichen vor allem immer
wieder zu der kernfrage zurück wie
gefährlich es dort bekommen wie
gefährlich ist natürlich haben wir eine
gefährdung des gesundheitssituation für
die ungeimpften aber für die kämpften
wie es die für die zweifach kämpften wie
gefährlich ist es da und wie gefährlich
ist es für gepostet und da hört man ja
eher wenn selbst hosten sie haben sie
vielleicht gelesen die letzten tage die
tonalität etwas verändert dann glaube
ich kann man erkennen dass das zumindest
wichtig ist es zu berücksichtigen
jetzt also da müssen wir noch über den
fc bayern sprechen und zwar nicht aus
sportlicher sicht sondern aus
gesundheitlicher sicht neun spieler sind
da in quarantäne
bei einem ähnlichen ausbruch
beispielsweise in der schulklasse dann
sind gleich alle weg und findet kein
unterricht mehr statt morgen gladbach
sollte es wird stattfinden
also die idee fiel hatte ihre eigenen
regeln und ich glaube der fc bayern hat
er beantragt dieses spiel zu verschieben
ich finde es wenn ich das als die fans
sagen dafür bauholz als jemand der sich
mit dem ganzen thema sehr beschäftige
ich fände es besser das würde verschoben
das ist nicht wettbewerbsfähigen in
sozusagen schloss stattfindet und wir
werden erleben das ist bei anderen
mannschaften aus sein kann und deswegen
wäre es besser das würde verschoben
werden man hat so ein bisschen das
gefühl so fc bayern muss halt jetzt auch
spielen egal wie vielleicht freut sich
auch der eine oder andere nicht fehlen
darüber dass ich natürlich den fc bayern
unterstütze ist was anderes aber
trotzdem finde ich es auch ehrlichkeit
fairness zu verschieben dann geht auch
diese frage an den fan markus söder und
nicht an dem politiker finden sie das ja
im nachhinein richtig gute idee von
manuel neuer über die tage nach ja auf
die malediven zu fliegen und dort daten
sich corona zu holen so war es
vermutlich nachdem er die ganze zeit
gesund war die ganze zeit getestet
worden die ganze zeit abgeschirmt wurde
war das leichtsinnig
das glaube ich nicht das kann ich nicht
beurteilen ist ja gewusst hat gewesen
man sieht dass es keine sicherheit gibt
und deswegen keine kritik an der stelle
aber den bürgern raten sie ab auch sie
von solchen reisen
wir haben ausdrücklich ja in deutschland
nicht gesagt man darf nicht in den
urlaub fahren denn das ist ja wie jemand
der gepustet ist beispielsweise der
wurde ja ausdrücklich nicht dies gesagt
und wir haben auch nicht gesagt dass man
nicht reisen dafür hatten es
beispielsweise sehr viele menschen die
in bayern im urlaub waren und das schöne
weihnachtsfeier tage verbracht haben mit
höchsten sicherheitsvorkehrungen
und nebenbei bemerkt wir haben erlebt
dass irgend möglich gewesen in einer
disco in schleswig holstein muss auch
sehr große probleme gewesen sein also
ist ein riesiges bretter event diana es
geheißen so also insofern objektiven
oder schleswig-holstein scheint die
herausforderung ähnlich groß gewesen zu
sein dennoch hat man das gefühl so ging
es mir zumindest manuel neuer sitzt in
der wahrscheinlich schönsten corona
quarantine etwa wenn sie auch gerne
wahlen quarantäne auf den malediven in
der neuer quarantäne
ich bin kein somali tiefe fan aber ich
gönne jedem er hinfährt ich bevorzuge
ich sage immer noch mal das nächste jahr
dann doch lieber bayern urlaub machen
aber ich bin ja kein großer fan davon
aber es ist auf jeden fall sieht halt an
der herausforderung bis zweifach du bist
gebucht dass du hältst dich an alles
also ja waren erneut weiß ich dass er
ein in jeder beziehung vorbildlicher
sportsmann ist und trotzdem kann es dich
erwischen alexander dobrindt unserer
landesgruppenvorsitzender hält sich auch
an aber deutlich an alles ich weiß es
selbst vielen gesprächen die situation
heute ist anders man mal wissen wir
einfach es gibt so viele leute die
wissen nicht wie sie angesteckt sind und
wenn wenn all die aussagen der experten
die ich befrage
richtig sind dann werden sich auch sehr
viele anstecken können die
möglicherweise sich trotzdem an alles
halten egal ob in den motiven auf
mallorca in mailand in münchen wo das
sonst so mailand und münchen hauptsache
spanien nur allerdings an der dobrindt
war auch nicht auf den malediven glaube
ich sie gehören persönlich zu dem
corolla gewinnern markus söder und zwar
deswegen weil sie den schlappmaul orden
aus ihrer heimat weiter behalten dürfen
das ist total ungewöhnlich es hat noch
niemand geschafft drei jahre
hintereinander schlappmaul orden was
macht sie persönlich zum längsten
schlappmaul das es je gab
ich hoffe nicht dass da das solide einer
verschwörungstheorie konstruiert wird
das genau nur aus diesem grund corona
sich entwickelt hätte und diesen
sicherlich fränkisch bedeutenden
faschingsorden an der stelle dazu
erhalten ich glaube den haben schon so
viele bekommen diesen orten unter
anderem auch da habe ich franz josef
strauß und andere ist sagen wir mal so
ein ort an dem man bekommt für eine
freudige
kommunikation die man nacht und eine
aktive und beides glaube ich das mache
ich und kann ich
dann also auch noch ein glückwunsch zu
diesem orden von unserer seite schlapp
mal ordentlich habe zum ersten mal davon
hat der schlappmaul ort oder sogar eine
wissenslücke die wir an dieser stelle
geschlossen haben bayerns
ministerpräsident ja sie sollten ihre
investigativ teams daran setzen noch die
bayern gibt es viele tolle offen wir
kurz
das tasten geheimnis noch lüften
sie bieten ja bei bild live immer
willkommen politische statements oft
auch über die taste r so etwas haben wir
womit hamas heute verleiht ich habe es
noch nicht genau gesehen
yoga oder weisheit und gelassenheit fürs
neue jahr gefallen wäre wäre gut also
yoga oder mio da kann man sehr gut ins
neue jahr starten finde ich gerade auch
vor so einer mpk weil man da immer lang
sitzt und wirklich viel geduld braucht
kann ich ihn wirklich nur nur sagen ja
das haben wir wenn wir auch
also letzter schluck die sitzen ja
soweit ich das verfolge sitzt der bild
live mit dabei am tisch war sie kennen
das sie als einzige richtig genau so
macht man das auch der magen dann bis
morgen am tisch lagen einem corona
gipfel danke fürs gespräch bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder